hello welcome to Google developers live
I'm Paul saxman a developer advocate on
the Google Maps API team and in this
video I cover the basics of adding
markers to a map using the Google Maps
Android API v2 markers are the
fundamental way to show position of
something on a map something in this
context can be a place such as a city
venue or landmark or it could be a
transient or moving objects such as a
person or vehicle essentially markers
can be used to represent anything that
has a global position in latitude and
longitude coordinates adding a marker to
the map is as simple as calling add
marker on the Google map object with a
marker options object as a parameter an
instance of a markers returned from add
marker so that you can later update or
remove the marker you can remove a map
marker by calling the remove method on
the marker instance when creating a
marker the marker options object needs
to be configured with a position in
lat/long coordinates but it also
supports a number of other optional
parameters for example you can create an
invisible marker which you can later
make visible or you can set the
transparency for a marker using the
Alpha property the default marker is a
red inverted teardrop which should be
familiar to most users however you can
easily change the color of a marker or
provide your own marker image using the
icon method and a bitmap descriptor
factory object we'll cover these
techniques in a video on creating custom
markers however since there are a number
of ways that you can change markers
appearance after a marker has been
created most of its properties like its
position visibility and icon can be
changed by calling corresponding mutator
methods on the marker class for example
if you want to toggle the visibility of
a marker you can call a set visible
method of a marker instance toggling
marker visibility is a great way to
implement place filtering since making
an initially invisible marker visible is
faster than creating a new marker
altogether for example if you want to
allow the user to hide or show hotels
with specific price or cost levels
you'll likely want to use marker
visibility instead of creating new
markers altogether to get the best
performance
if you want to show a small amount of
information on the map along with the
marker you can add up title and snippet
to your marker using the corresponding
methods on the marker options class the
title and snippet are displayed in an
info window a bubble over over the
marker when the user touches the marker
you can also programmatically show or
hide the info window using this show
info window and hide in for window
methods of a marker instance you can
fully customize the appearance of the
info window using an info window adapter
however since there are a couple of ways
that you can customize him if a window
will cover these techniques in a
separate video as well if you want to
take some other action when a user
touches a marker besides showing an info
window you can implement an on marker
click listener and assign an instance of
your listener to the Google map class
when a user touches the marker the on
marker click method of your adapter
instance is called with a reference to
the marker that was clicked it can
therefore be useful to maintain a
hashmap of markers that you've created
in order to look up and display more
information about the place or object
associated with a marker for example if
you use markers to represent hotels and
you want to show details about a hotel
in a separate view when a user touches a
hotel marker you can use a hashmap to
look up the hotel description using a
clicked marker as the key so now you
should have know how to get started with
markers if you'd like more information
check out our documentation and watch
the show about custom markers in the
meantime have fun making remarkable Maps
thanks for joining and hope to see you
soon